all right so thanks everybody for coming
out it was a great one make sure you hit
like share subscribe and until then
we'll see you guys next week all right
is that it Ben Simon Oh what was it I
was number nine nine nine all right
let's do it one thousand well come on
let's just go let's just go do it now
let's just go film one thousand one
thousand come on what are you waiting
for we got to go one thousand
all right Mike you ready for this oh
thank you sir
let's go do this one thousand one
thousand videos let's do it so both of
these games were less than ten moves
long and I won both of them when I was
white when I was black okay which one
should we look at first let's look at
the one I was white because I won that
one 31 years ago okay so let's look at
that one
now don't blink it sit in soon wow that
was it okay now we'll look at Game two
now Queen d3 is risky because he'll take
it that's that's that's the one o'clock
class okay Queen is e1 now Black has all
these tricks and white stops all those
tricks you guys found all the tricks you
know why those tricks are for kids don't
do that that's the one o'clock class he
didn't want to lose his rook so he
didn't make sense
he played Queen to d2 now in the one
o'clock class they would probably play
Bishop takes Queen and then I would that
would be illegal then let's go back to
12 o'clock class eventually I wake up at
5:00 a.m. if you like that enough it's
sort of weird yeah well it is French so
anyway so in this position I made the
most unusual of moves I made the
position totally symmetrical where
everything was the same how did I do
that
what
what move that makes it totally
symmetrical someone teach this kid what
symmetrical means yeah everything is the
exact same no I took and he took back
now that's symmetrical right okay and I
played here and he copied me and I
raised my hand and I'm like Mike comer
he can't copy me is that what I did yeah
yeah by the way if your point is copying
you is that allowed
if you think the answer is no I got one
thing to say to you
one o'clock class okay all right
so I played C for an explosive move be
very good now if I can find this game
which is the zero percent chance I'm
going to find anyway
I like a challenge because it reminds me
of that game in the opposite way does it
care about capitalization a nerdling er
but now okay okay one of my favorite
games that i noth mike shadi not my dad
ah ah Mike I got my ex-wife my dad my
brother and Mike shadi and I have Greg
shadi vs. my ex-wife okay here's the
game that's pretty funny yeah that we
got we got four fine golds and thing and
they got three shot ease so there's a
lot of stuff going on there Greg Shia
beat my ex-wife and 16 was the one dried
divorced er okay terrible then I married
the wrong one
ah vampire girl what a hoot yeah we're
looking at that at the top thousand
videos we've ever made we can't forget
that time vara Cobian was talking to
that kid about the Dutch defense let's
have a look what is the name of this
opening who knows it this is actually
quite popular there are many very top
players play this world champions play
this and it's popular opening who plays
this opening can you also name at least
one Grand Master who plays this
Dutch defense and radium and a
grandmaster from Brazil and Dutch
anybody else who is the number one
played us in us now currently okay
he is the expert of this opening he
played many times this one Dutch defense
and number one in the world who is he he
played this also remember this this is
how you play against the Dutch takes
Knight takes Knight f6 Bishop g5
well it's better to follow one of our
our favorite moments here on the YouTube
channel was obviously beginner breakdown
one of the longest running series right
here my comer he's the man that did it
all most entertaining man in chess
lots of fun with him my favorite Mike
Hummer moment was the meaning of life
revealed video nothing changed my life
more than that excellent life coach and
my favorite part of that that particular
one and I know like every line it was
such a such a classic episode was when
Darcy was looking in the box and she was
taken up back let's go ahead and have a
look at it and what I have inside this
box contains the meaning of life yeah so
I showed one of my co-workers Darcy what
was in this box and she was taken aback
and then I'm like yeah you can't handle
what was in the box
well alright so we're all gonna die can
everybody agree with that all right
we're all gonna die so let's say why
even bother what why don't we just man
we just you know just yes just be
miserable you know we're gonna die it's
a realization okay alright so it's
alright so I'm playing white against
this miserable miserable guy this was
back in 96 as well alright so I'm white
and we play the Petroff defense okay so
I attack his knight and so he attacks my
knight I take his knight okay so so he
thinks he has his Queen on e7 okay so he
plays the move oh all right yeah you
can't do that right so but you touched
your King so you have to play something
right so they're only legal movies here
and then we easily win his queen with a
double check so the King moves Knight
all right so so this is like a lot of
people all right
you know something tragic happens in the
first part of their life and you know
tragedy struck you know there's nothing
enough to do all right so I got news for
everybody tragedy happens to everybody
you're not special unfortunately okay
and it's like we got to get up from this
okay so quick story all right before I
was a you know just superstar you know I
worked at stocking shelves at a grocery
stores okay it was an awesome awesome
time here and it was a lot of fun at
first okay but then you know management
got in my my way and stuff and Emma
they're throwing boxes into the baler
all right everybody know what a baler is
it's a compressor that turns all the
boxes into basically one big box okay
and very sad very sad so if you saw the
look on my face it was like it was bad
so so I decide to choices at that time I
could jump into the baler you know it
just just ended a hole or or you know I
could just quit my job and move on but
anyway I quit my job and I became the
super story that I am okay if there's
something bad going in your life get
over it get over yourself already and
get on with your life
which is
all right so you ready for me to open up
the box it should be pretty obvious what
it is though after watching that clip
alright here it is the meaning of life
getting glory by being awesome
so girls cheer for you people yell about
how great you are your meta Me's get so
irritated and befuddled by you and most
importantly so you have an amazing
reason to celebrate with your friends so
that is the meaning of life you don't
have to be Michael Jordan you don't have
to be a state senator don't have to be
the richest man in the world you cannot
get it on a the coldest night on a
Tuesday that was amazing thanks Mike for
all the great memories that's fantastic
cheers my good man and here's some
never-before-seen footage featuring
thore OGG we're just going to go on an
adventure tonight something's going to
happen ah
and so okay this is the biggest prize
we've ever given away at a Monday night
mayhem tournament so I thought you know
mayhem is in the title you never know
what to expect when you play in this
tournament and with it all in the line
now we're going to use the raw 6000 to
choose the opening for tonight it as
promised we're going to do a nonsense
opening now these openings are so bad I
don't even want to touch them with my
fingers so these are just you know the
dirtiest worst openings that you guys
have ever selected and okay I was going
to sit here and reveal all of the names
to you but apparently there are some
names that are just so inappropriate
then it could get me fired for even
reading the names so let's see we got to
dig around in the trash see we're going
to find these bad openings and
I'm so angry so nothing's working right
so all right so like we got this big
thing like even my wrong has a box but
alright so so very very frustrating
alright well we'll just turn on the rug
we'll see what we get we know it's going
to be something bad could be the most
controversial episode ever like who
knows if it's I guess some people would
have you know taken the bad ones out but
who knows this could be the last episode
ever I might get fired for this so
nobody knows all right let's just turn
on the other raagh oh wait I got turning
I got do my my personal hmm alright and
commence alright let's look at the rug
fire it up
I'll let's get this thing going ah all
right excellent
so go ahead let's see let's see let's
get this opening alright let's see oh
man oh man oh man alright thank you
let's check it out let's see what it is
oh it's a bad one it's it's the Grob so
we're actually doing this huh we're
doing this alright thank you and
deactivate all right so let's mentally
prepare ourselves to do the Grob
yeah dude and then I have to teach the
grog yeah there's been lots of fun times
here at the Chess Club and now let's go
in the head and hear what Ben Simon
behind the camera you don't get to hear
him too much he must have some favorite
moments what do you got for us Ben
thanks Jonathan you know a thousand
videos that's a lot of footage plenty of
it ends up on the cutting room floor
some of that footage contains
Grandmaster Yassir Sarah want then
feingold vara Cobian many others and
I've enjoyed watching it here's a few
clips you might enjoy as well that just
didn't make the final cut okay I'll just
go with castles castles and here he
played 96 map normally and this could
happen on the move before as well
you can play C takes d4 Knight takes d4
this machine is always talking I don't
know why we'll have to shush it one day
96 and that's a normal way to play
towards the center fight for the center
I didn't play that much and in this
position I guess I mean some old can I
change the mode of this one nothing I
press nothing I think it's in some sort
of a playing mode or what the heck
and that's for sure yeah and we also
don't want it to talk so I definitely
don't want to go here because if I want
Bishop f4 then the pawn will take on d4
let me show you how it's done let's say
here and then pawn takes if the machine
will allow it Emme is talking also this
is something you see different but my
point is yeah I'm holding nothing and of
course if you take back then oops if
it's allowed to do it you can see that
this is just a fork a simple fork
attacking the knight attacking the
bishop bad news for white so okay we
don't want that to happen obviously also
white is another little trap let's
pretend for a moment that this is white
to move well let me just play some silly
move for black let's pretend black plays
this just for fun now
White has a beautiful little sacrifice
how do we do that try to think in the
meantime the machine is just talking and
talking and it already not only saying
it already moved it's already spoiling
my questions
this machine is terrible afterwards the
idea is to play rook takes a seven that
is a tremendous threat because after
rook takes a seven-night takes f6 check
and then after this we just take here
and you can see that this is just
checkmate teawrex how do you stop the
maid here or here there is just no way
no way you can stop it some of you might
say wait a minute why didn't he just
take this guy and the reason is rook to
c8 is very very strong just a monster
little move after which there's just
nothing you can do
I'm threatening you rook I'm threatening
to play rook to e8 winning your queen
and if you take and I take with the
bishop I'm attacking the rook and I'm
threatening rookie a Czech winning the
Queen
game over so quickly and black had to
resign
why because of course after rook takes
simply look to c8 and the game is over
yet the machine is always talking so
I've given up on it
so after rook C check of course after we
run a whole night we suck the Queen for
the night but now we are going to win
the Queen free and clear
after this check if it's going to let me
do it today yes now now all right you
guys understand right rook c8 is coming
in the game you just move this bishop if
you take the C pawn right here then
after rook F 2 I'm going to attack the
Queen and protect my other beep on the
Queen we'll have one of two choices now
it's screaming but if you play the move
f6 right now then I will start playing
moves like g4 and I'm going to bring my
queen and my other rook over and h4 and
g5 and all my pawns are going to I'm
going to basically play on five ranks
and you're going to play on three and
I'm going to eventually open up the
position anyway so if you wanted to play
a four very nice Oh actually I think you
designed here because yeah because if he
takes back then simply rook captures d5
threatening the Queen and also
threatening rook to b8 mate for my next
class if this thing talks I'm leaving
the class that's all I'm telling and
back in 2013 yasser was commissioned to
make a series of very simple how they
move shorts basically how each piece on
the chessboard moved and those chess
fanatics out there who use chess
software know a glitch can ruin your day
and on this particular day it was move
number one white to play or so he
thought
from our starting position we're going
to look at nights let's imagine that
white opens up what's going on doesn't
my son making a little move is the the
the position is kind of reversed itself
the colors reverse themselves how did
that happen
come and check this out because this is
kind of actually funny so I was saying
that the knight wants to go to f3 won't
let me do it I've given black the move
somehow it was making me blush first
yeah I don't know how I did that I don't
think I could repeat that even if I
tried
position set up clear board reset okay
we're going to okay no worries position
said huh
did I click something move number okay
well we don't want black moving first no
we don't teach right okay just a second
so we can go insert position set up
position set up clear board reset okay
I just don't understand and okay that's
not the position setup move number Oh
psyching up there's no thank you
okay clear board reset okay wait it was
stolen black I don't know why it's Auto
selecting black to move first for some
reason so let's try it okay now all
right now let's start boom cool okay
yeah nailed it nailed it side to move
okay
alright thanks Ben Simon for all the
great videos things here too Mike thanks
to all the grandmasters that have made
this YouTube channel a big success I
don't forget to like or you know just
like we're trying to you know make or
more great content we've got a thousand
more videos to come so we did it a
thousand videos thousand videos you
ready boys